is there any I know we can't I don't
wanna get into the minutiae of every
ceasefire and everything that's
happening right now does this thing ever
will this thing ever end a full
disclosure I don't know that I ever
tried to hide this but I'm Jewish
culturally my points are Jewish
obviously you're yeah and that's the
thing like and because I'm you know
young please let's just say I'm young
yeah okay perfect that you know like I
don't feel traditionally you know like I
don't I don't feel like I have this
allegiance because I'm supposed to have
an allegiance but I I do feel for the
Jewish people in general I mean we're
what less than 2% of the world
population we've been kicked out of
every country we've ever lived in yeah
the world I like I'm so glad I'm not
super famous because we've taken totally
out of context but like if you were just
looking at the stats it would be easy to
say the world hates Jews yeah and that's
just the way it is it's not Jon Stewart
everyone seems to love Jon Stewart you
know what it's funny you should say that
too because I lost a lot of respect for
Jon Stewart lately especially when he
did the bit where you know he said
Israel and all these people started
yelling at him I don't know who the
people are that and maybe it's just
because they're not in my social circle
or even on social media but everyone
says Oh everyone's supporting Israel I
don't know anyone who's supporting
Israel outside you know of this
conversation I don't know anyone who who
is actually in my opinion looking at
this in a fair way and I understand and
you know you you hear people say well
the Jews said after the Holocaust never
again okay on one hand that means why
would you put another group of people in
the same position that you were in on
the other hand it means never again this
is not going to happen to us again so
we're gonna have to fight and we're
gonna have to fight harder this time the
old bar has a great line about that he
said you know everyone said in during
the Holocaust well why did the Jews just
go to the ovens and now they fight back
in different says well why do they fight
back so that's a perfect segue to my
second question is there any other
country or place on earth that is
accused of disproportionate force :
Powell had the Powell doctrine which
means that if you get into an armed
conflict you crush them to the point
where they give up immediately now
that's not what Israel is doing because
they're doing all this targeted stuff
and we know Hamas is literally hiding
it's in UN schools this is a fact I know
people are gonna be happier but it's a
fact but is there what is
disproportionate what does that mean in
war has anyone the United States in Iraq
would qualify as disproportionate since
we shouldn't have done it in the first
place so but these are this is just
going to be if you are a supporter of
Israeli policy then you were not going
to think it's disproportionate and if
you are not then you were going to think
it's disproportionate so it just it just
this is I feel like a lot of it just
breaks down like it's your team like I'm
on the that's my team like a sports team
and whatever they do like I mean I'm
from Boston I grew up you know as a fan
of the Celtics and I actually found
myself rooting for Danny Ainge and he
was a horrible horrible person and a
horrible player I mean we're not a bad
player but and but he was on my team so
I had root for him and then once he left
he was the biggest [ __ ] in the world
a really good point though can I just
leave it I think you're so right I think
that people are so used to just having
their own conversations that pipes up
their own point and then the other
side's doing that and we're just going
to keep building this but if we can just
if somebody and people do this a lot
night I respect it and I'm happy that it
happens somebody who doesn't believe
what I believe makes a decent point then
it breaks that down a little bit I'm
like okay I see what you're saying and
that actually helps me understand the
other side here's what I'm saying and
that never happens yes and that's
exactly why I preface this the way I did
and that I want this conversation to be
a real thing and I do believe peace is
possible it's gonna take it's gonna take
a lotta stuff but I don't think
everything is equal and we do have a
bizarre moral equivalent some people can
argue with me about that I in terms of
your first question which I didn't
really answer oh and I have no sympathy
for the right-wing Israeli government I
have no sympathy for right-wing
government's anywhere generally I have
no sympathy for Hamas really and I think
that the part of the problem if you you
talk about is they're gonna meet you
know you can be solved in six months one
of the real issues is that the people of
Israel and the people of the Palestinian
people really do detest each other and
with with legitimate legitimate
grievances on both sides and I mean if
you go to I mean it's we hear about how
Hamas is their textbooks are in there
they're their children's shows are all
about how the Jews of the devil and so
on and so forth which is stupid and it's
counterproductive
and that but then if you go to say the
the West Bank can you go to the
checkpoint so you see how the Israeli
soldiers treat the Palestinian children
and humiliate people are trying to come
into Israel and pointlessly so that it's
bred from childhood on both sides and I
don't believe that Hamas and I don't
believe the right-wing Israeli
government either them are all the
interested in peace unfortunately but
it's going to take the people of Israel
in the people of the Palestinian people
working independently and not often at
cross-purposes to their own governments
to achieve peace and do it on a personal
personal level which is incredibly
difficult and it's asking a lot it's
easy for me to say that over here but I
bet that's the way I feel that well I
think you made a couple extremely good
points there and that's the irony of if
you're defending Hamas right now you're
actually not defending the idea of a
Palestinian state because they left in
the first place so if you want them to
pull out of the West Bank which by the
way they've offered to do a who'd only
made an offer in two thousand ninety
percent of what the Palestinians say
they want Arafat just didn't respond
he made no counter proposal just didn't
respond it's in Bill Clinton's book I'm
sorry as I say a hoot Barak or yeah I
did so and then Omer the Prime Minister
in 2008 made an offer of 97 percent
including a refugee issue including
Jerusalem and there was no Abbas just
didn't show up to the meeting the next
day so there's a litany of stuff we
can't
who's Pro Palestine and they will
provide a litany of their own of
grievances against that those offers
which why they weren't legitimate stones
over and the conversation but you know
no one no one gets all they want so
let's say the offer of 90% was actually
the 80% which no one says it's like well
with the Devils in the detail what were
you offering what you know who's gonna
control the water who's gonna control
the board I mean that's it's all I mean
these conversations they spiral and it's
it's the same as the conversation about
who's fault who's to blame who started
it yeah you know that's so shows how
often is the conversation that's why I
didn't want to start with that but
that's the converse and at some point in
time I feel like we all have to rise
above that and say okay we're gonna just
put this to bed and we're gonna put this
to rest and we're not gonna quibble over
the history let's just move forward and
not argue about that and just argue
about what we can do in the future
because if we if we continue quibble
over the past it never ends
and that's why I didn't start there
yeah I was gonna say that yeah you make
some such a great point about how in
general you know we're we're constantly
told that these people hate each other
it is to the meril of their being it
cannot change and then you know you you
talked about how the Israeli soldiers
have you know humiliate the children and
all this stuff and and I I haven't seen
anything on that it's probably true I
don't know but it just got me the the
word propaganda just flashed through my
head I get you know things about Israel
I get things about Palestine all the
time
and I see these pictures of Israeli
soldiers helping Palestinian children or
helping older Palestinian men and they
say these are the pictures that are
never going to get circulated so we're
so far away and it's so tiny how do we
know what to believe right I mean I
don't think even on this network we
haven't done any stories about the the
hospital that Israel built right outside
of Gaza to bring in wounded people now
yes you could say they've attacked
hospitals there so okay we haven't done
any stories on the hospital that they
built for wounded Syrians this is a
country that they're technically at war
with so I know none of this stuff ever
ends anyway I hope we gave you a little
something there that shows a little
degree of tolerance and that we don't
all have to agree on everything but
maybe everyone could tone down the
rhetoric a little bit and kind of
challenge your preconceived notions as
I've tried to do myself